bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour le
7 8 sur tvfils 78 durant une heure nous
allons faire le tour de l'actualité
locale comme chaque soir en direct de 18
à 19h du lundi au jeudi le tour de
l'actualité avec nos invités bien sûr a
commencé par Olivier Lebrun bonsoir et
bienvenue sur ce plateau conseiller
général UMP des Yvelines également maire
de Viroflay vous avez présenté cet
après-midi le plan de protection de
l'enfance du département c'était à
Versailles et nous allons le détailler
dans quelques minutes je recevrai aussi
ce soir la chef de chœur de l'Ensemble
Vocal de 50 ans en Yvelines et qui
s'apprête à rendre hommage à André chez
did dans le cadre du Printemps des
poètes et puis au cours de la chronique
économie en seconde partie d'émission
nous aurons également deux invités pour
nous accompagner claire bonsoir bonsoir
la troisième édition de la Semaine de
l'industrie se déroule jusqu'au 24 mars
son objectif est de renforcer
l'attractivité du secteur de l'industrie
de ces métiers nous ferons le point sur
cette semaine avec les temps forts et
nous recevrons à ce sujet une ingénieur
du secteur chef de projet à Renault
jusqu'au 23 mars aussi la semaine créer
son entreprise un événement organisé par
la BGE un réseau d'appui aux
entrepreneurs nous recevrons le
directeur de la BGE Yvelines Michel
Zella rendez-vous donc dans une
demi-heure pour la chronique de l'Echo
sur TVfil voici à présent les titres de
ce 21 mars les sujets que vous
découvrirez tout à l'heure en images la
Semaine de l'Industrie claire en parlait
partout en France et dans les Yvelines
également l'occasion de dresser le bilan
d'un secteur qui représente 19% de
l'activité du département un secteur qui
cherche à séduire notamment un public
féminin en ce 21 mars journée
internationale de sensibilisation à la
trisomie 21 pour faire changer le regard
évoluer les mentalités nous vous
proposons le portrait d'une mini
Montaine Elia elle a 18 ans une jeune
fille trisomique épanouie vous le voyez
qui multiplie les activités elle vit
presque comme une ado de son âge elle le
festival d'humour de Rocquencourt s'est
ouvert ce mercredi soir et pour encore
deux soirées dédiées à des jeunes
humoristes le premier lauréat puisque
c'est également un concours s'appelle
Alex visorec et vous l'ENT endrez tout à
l'heure la mobilisation contre le
mariage pour tous qui se poursuivent
Philippe Rio conseiller général UMP mère
du Chesnay l'un des principaux leaders
de la contestation sera présent dimanche
lors de la mobilisation du défilé
parisien et ce malgré les interdictions
de défiler sur les Champs-Élysées
Philippe Briot je le rappelle est à
l'initiative de cette pétition pour
demander la saisine du 16e le Conseil
économique et social et saisine rejeté
malgré quelques 700 000 signatures on
l'écoute c'était aujourd'hui
730 000 pétitions rejetées par un bureau
c'est un scandale il faut être clair et
le deuxième point c'est que le rejet
d'une grande avenue à Paris pour que
nous puissions manifester pacifiquement
c'est aussi anormal et que la façon dont
l'Assemblée nationale a traité le texte
a été aussi quand même
nous a interpellé et quand j'ai entendu
il y a trois jours même Toby radir dans
l'arène je sabre ça donne un peu quand
même
la sensation au niveau de l'Assemblée
nationale par contre au niveau du Sénat
les choses se passent différemment je
pense donc on va se tourner beaucoup
vers le Sénat pour voir si c'est sage
peuvent trouver justement
le moyen de pouvoir réunir les Français
de les unir dans une alliance en faveur
d'un mariage intelligent
et nous aurons l'occasion de poser cette
question justement à l'ancien président
du Sénat Gérard Larcher sénateur maire
de Rambouillet il sera sur le plateau du
7 8 sur TVfil le jeudi 4 avril Olivier
Lebrun donc conseillé général
UMP des Yvelines vous êtes venu nous
parler du Plan de Protection de dans le
département mis en place par le Conseil
Général j'aimerais tout de même votre
sentiment sur cette mobilisation des
opposants à ce mariage pour tous le
projet doit passer au Sénat au tout
début du mois d'avril la mobilisation
malgré la manifestation qui sera
compliquée ce week-end ne faiblit pas on
le voit bien effectivement cette
mobilisation actuellement on a beaucoup
de personnes qui distribuent des tracks
qui collent des affiches pour
remobiliser les opposants je le disais
en introduction mais je le reprécise
voilà nous effectivement je me suis j'ai
participé au déjà aux deux
manifestations innovembre une en janvier
et dont je pense qu'il faut continuer à
se mobiliser pour faire comprendre à ce
gouvernement que les Français ne sont
pas tous d'accord avec cette cette loi
donc
et qui est une loi qui change de façon
fondamentale la vision de la famille en
fait qu'on peut avoir en France et vous
serez présent donc à Paris ce week-end
mars et puis je le rappelle l'examen de
la loi par le Sénat par ce projet de loi
pardon permettant le mariage aux
personnes de même sexe ce sera des le 2
avril on passe à présent à notre sujet
du jour la protection de l'enfance